he's been the face of the high street
for decades
now his business empire lies in ruins
you need
to leave but you're not understanding
sky news has learned that the philip
green's arcadia group owner of topshop
burton and miss selfridge
is preparing to appoint administrators
within days
it would leave 13 000 jobs at risk and
thousands of pension scheme members
worrying about their futures
the company has been a casualty of the
coronavirus and its own failure to keep
pace with changing shopping habits
could philip green have prevented this
happening
um i dare say he could chuck
a load more money in the business and
kick the can down the road
further but the the reality is that
most of the businesses in his empire
um are at the end of their
life cycle but it wasn't always this way
the tycoon took control of arcadia in
2002
and paid a 1.2 billion pounds dividend
one of the biggest ever seen in britain
to his wife just three years later
in 2012 he sold a 25 stake in top shop
valuing it at 2 billion pounds so philip
people want to know why you're on
holiday
when they think that you're supposed to
be sorting out the pension debt
but more recent times have seen the
monaco-based billionaire's reputation
trashed
as he was hauled before parliament and
faced repeated calls to be stripped of
his knighthood
in many ways the decline of arcadia has
been a long time coming
a rescue deal with creditors last year
provided only a stay of execution
and its imminent collapse will only fuel
the controversy surrounding a tycoon
whose language was as colorful as his
lifestyle
arcadia's collapse will come just four
years after bhs's demise cost 11
000 jobs within 13 months of sir
phillips selling it for a pound
bhs pension campaigner lim mcmillan was
one of a number of former employees who
fought to get sir philip to pay out
ultimately ending in him handing over
360 million pounds
thousands of people um the worry as we
approach
christmas of whether they're going to
have a job or not
it sounds all too familiar i'm afraid
in a statement today arcadia said the
forced closure of our stores for
sustained periods as a result of the
covid19 pandemic
has had a material impact on trading
across our businesses
as a result the arcadia boards have been
working on a number of contingency
options
to secure the future of the group's
brands administrators from deloitte are
likely to be in place at arcadia on
monday
it looks like the end of the reign for
the high street's one-time
king mark kleinman sky news